defiance on the streets of Srinagar it's
the largest city and the summer capital
of indian-administered Kashmir
protesters chanted pro-pakistan slogans
and demanded an end to what they
described as Indian occupation of their
territory Kashmir has been controversial
since 1947 when India and Pakistan
divided it but continued to dispute
ownership but two months ago in their
evoked the special legal status for
Kashmir that had been enshrined in its
constitution that ended the region's
autonomy including its ability to enact
its laws it also scrapped legal
restrictions on outsiders owning and
settling on land death now many
residents fear the move is part of a
plan by New Delhi to change the makeup
of its people thousands of Indian army
and security personnel have been
deployed and security crackdown posed
communications blocked and there are
severe restrictions on movement hundreds
of political leaders and activists have
also been detained people say there are
only soldiers on the streets and their
lives and businesses have been disrupted
it has only been three months since we
unveiled the our new show and we
invested a huge amount of money on this
particular project the clam don't happen
and it's been almost sixty days since it
happened so right now I'm in a bit of a
worry but I'm hoping that it gets back
to normal as soon as possible some
people have found themselves stranded we
are facing many difficulties because of
the prevailing situation after eight
days my daughter was discharged from
hospital I need to take her home from
last two hours I'm looking for a vehicle
but I'm not able to find any I live very
far away from here this parent says many
are afraid to send their children to
school this way home dirt we are scared
the government has opened the schools
but kids are not going we the parents
are worried for them how can we send our
children to school what if they don't
come back
well whoppers me
in these new measures have inflamed
decades-long tensions with Pakistan on
the other side of the dividing line
during the last few weeks that sled two
military clashes both from the air and
on land and concerns in the wider region
were possible all-out war between the
two nuclear powers mohammad van al
jazeera